It's Sunday, which means it is football day.
And around here we are house divided.
We do not root for the same teams.
But today our teams are playing a different times.
So I am playing the supportive wife role
and I am supporting his favorite teams. Colors,
if you know. You know,
it is giving off those vibes.
Teal and orange, it is perfect.
I can be the supportive wife,
cheer on his team without cheering on his team.
You know, I love this shirt.
It is lightweight, it is super soft,
perfect for fall. And it comes in a lot of different colors.
So if you want to be a supportive wife,
get yourself one of these shirts.
And if you don't like football
and you don't wanna be a supportive wife,
check out the other colors because they are amazing.